well today I'm talking with William
Burroughs about this enjoyable book the
asteroid threat I guess I would
characterize it as the story of how
astronomers planetary scientists base
engineer who might someday save the
world and well how would you
characterize your book I think you did
it very well I would characterize it by
saying that my point is that we are not
we don't have to be the appleís helpless
victims of nature my friends in NASA and
elsewhere in the space community like to
say that the dinosaurs that have a space
program that still be here we have got
to wherewithal to save ourselves and the
book the most important point of the
book is that it explains that and comes
out with a plan and the plan was not
invented by me is pretty universally
accepted within the community so my
impression at least you're advocating us
spending quite a lot more on on this
problem on planetary defense is that
right yes the Cold War is over peace
alas has broken out and what I like to
tell people who say it will cost an
astronomical amount of money pardon the
pun to do this I say what is your
collective life as a civilization worth
the dinosaurs got blown away it can
happen again the chances are it's not
going to happen very soon but doomsday
is always a possibility so what I'm
saying is protect yourself that is a
very good use of money yeah so what are
you advocating that people should do say
if you had a few billion dollars or you
were king of the world what do you think
is the right thing to do well I would
set up a permanent planetary defense
system and again within the community
this is acknowledged as having three
parts part one is you've got to have the
sensors on the planet infrared sensors
on the planet and off the planet
to spot any so-called earth crosser any
potential impactor that is coming this
way and it looks like it's going to hit
part two is you've got to be able with
20 or more years notice you've got to be
able to send a spacecraft out that will
nudge it off course long before it gets
here and given the distance nudge it off
budget of course but just a tiny amount
will do it it will pass for white of the
planet the third part of the strategy is
last-ditch and that is being able to
stop it violently probably with a nuke
if everything else fails and it looks
like there's going to be an impact so
they're spending a lot of efforts to
find these things Congress passed the
bill they put up some money there you
know that there are these programs you
talk about notably the linear program
and kattiline Observatory pan-starrs
like that
I suppose is another one that will come
online in a few years that's of LSST the
large synoptic survey telescope are
those going to do the deal in terms of
finding the asteroids or do we need to
build more well they should pretty well
do it but there's also as I mentioned in
the book Sentinel which is an infrared
telescope you're planning on putting in
2017 they're planning on putting into a
Venus like orbit from where it will
watch the neighborhood as I call it and
pick up anything again that looks
threatening you can't have too many odds
and the community is in agreement on
that
so yes everything you mentioned is in
play and Sentinel should be in play too
so Sentinel funded it's going concerned
it will be up there in 2017 as far as we
know that is the plan it is being funded
by a
in Colorado Ball Aerospace &
Technologies Corp and the b612
Foundation which is astronauts former
astronauts rusty Schweikart Ned Lou
started with some other people they are
actually going to build it and then it
will get put into space as I say I think
in 2017 that's the plan so it's it's
it's the private sector so the money we
don't have and that we do need to
protect the planet then is for a
spacecraft that would go out and
actually meet the Beast right and
there's no plan to build those things
right now that correct well on its being
it's being thought about but is it
concrete no it is it is all theory and
but for the whole order of magnitude
about what those cost you think I as far
as I know that has not been determined
but it's obviously multiple billions but
again what's your life worth yeah right
so how probable is it what what chance
the people listening to this have of
getting killed by an asteroid by
whatever else would come along and well
how does that compare to whatever else
would come along good question
the chances of getting knocked off by an
asteroid are very very very slim there
is an inverse law here and then is earth
gets pelted all the time as you know buy
everything from pebbles to boulders to
larger rocks and so on we're constantly
being hit by any of so-called near-earth
objects the chances of the big one
coming along which would be a planet
killer or very remote they think that
the next time will be in about a hundred
and by that time we should be prepared
to do something about it but as I say
it is the smaller ones that will ruin
your day they can take out large tracts
of area and it has happened judging by
the number of impact craters on this
planet it happened well over 130 times
yeah and of course it's a random process
so it could be happening in the next
minute and and we wouldn't know
necessarily fisheries so I read in the
book that getting killed by an asteroid
is a little bit less probable than dying
an airplane crash is that a fair
statement that is absolutely right as I
say it's a it's it's the inverse law the
chances are very remote but if it
happens it can be devastating so I would
guess that one result of this program so
far finding all these asteroids you
found a lot of asteroids with these
monitoring programs that we actually now
know that a lot of asteroids that are
not going to hit us and we haven't found
any that will so probably not that
probably will be down just a song right
I mean it said we're a little we know
we're a little safer than we knew before
is that a fair statement I think we'll
watch safer and there's another element
to this and that is the little prince
who loved the asteroid he lived on I had
a point
asteroids are not all bad asteroids have
got some potentially very very useful
qualities one is a lot of them are
loaded with precious metals that can be
mined another is very big ones can be
lived on and that's in preparation for a
lunar colony which is in the book
lunar colony being something I believe
very strongly so the point is asteroids
are a mixed bag getting in close turning
into meteors
do terrible damage has happened last
year in Chelyabinsk in Russia the town
where wood blew up over the town and
sent more than 1,400 people to the
hospital who were injured
so there are pluses and minuses yeah
fortunately didn't kill anybody right it
was just a lot of flying broken glass
and people being thrown around and
thankfully they were lucky that it blew
up where it blew up because had it blown
up exploded over the city at a lower
altitude it could have been horrendous
death and destruction yeah I remember
reading that and in some way while
asteroids early in the history of the
Earth may have sterilized the planet
over and over several times that maybe
actually they were sort of like our
planetary life lifeboats that a big
asteroid will throw things out into
space and some of these rocks may be
infected by the early bacteria and such
that were on the planet and then were
sterilized but some of these bacteria
can remain alive in space capable of
getting going again and reproducing and
those rocks a lot of them ended back on
earth but you have to have a really big
asteroid to do that you have to
basically open up our vacuum cavity in
the atmosphere to get those rocks to fly
out so they are the destroyers and the
creators perhaps but you said something
also about people's ideas about
asteroids and comets bringing in organic
material from out outside well that's a
theory propounded it's out of my head
now but did the Comets in fact did bring
life to this planet which has not been
disproven yeah it's not a theory that
people talk about as much maybe but but
yes so how why do you think the audience
is for this I mean it's a candid
question how
what fraction of the populace thinks it
knows the difference between an asteroid
versus the comet versus a major planet
or whatever ever you having a feel for
that my guess is it's a very very small
percentage of the population when I
taught journalism at NYU I sent my
reporting students out one day to
interview the proverbial man on the
street about what he or she thinks about
the space program and they came back and
one said Professor burrows the lady I
talked to said that she's more
interested in educating her children a
man said actually I Morris didn't paying
the mortgage somebody else said putting
food on the table so the answer to your
very good question is a very small
percentage people are worried about
keeping the roof on and I don't mean the
roof that protects us against NGOs I
mean literally do roof on the house and
that's where it is but it seems to me at
least in the recent paths Congress has
been motivated about this question so
that's important and but are you
thinking of how to get the word out
about this threat and how we need to
spend more money than we are now less
where was the book yeah I was I was
privileged to be picked as the only non
scientist on the 14 member panel by the
National Research Council which is of
course a National Academy Sciences to be
on and on a near Earth object survey and
mitigation panel a few years back on
that we took testimony in Washington
Tucson and in Santa Fe from scientists
and that's how I got interested in it
because they they said that it's a
serious problem again
doomsday around the corner but I got
interested in it participating in that I
was very privileged to have been picked
for it it's a real problem as you well
know yeah so do you think they picked
you because they knew you would write a
book like this or
yes it was an active fish okay so you
know sitting here being somewhat
depressive I could imagine all sorts of
things that might wipe out the human
race I could you know people now think
that what 71 thousand years ago we were
almost wiped out by a giant volcano in
Indonesia and you know other volcanoes
wiped out almost all life a quarter
billion years ago and I can imagine some
really bad virus or something like that
so is is that the asteroid threat really
the worst thing we've gotta to steel
ourselves for or is it one of the tough
ones or have you thought about that
answer words there's one the - thing
about asteroids is you know was big ones
can do a lot of damage the good news is
they can be stopped as the late gene
shoemaker a geologist and de facto
planetary scientist as he pointed out
asteroids can be stopped hurricanes
typhoons earthquakes can't so that's the
difference the bad news is of course if
you're a dinosaur watch em the good news
is they can in fact be deflected or
stopped and that's part of again what
you know where was the book I should
also say they get back to your question
that I'm also advocating a permanent
colony on the Moon and Mars Buzz Aldrin
co-authored a book called rendezvous
with Tiber in which the heroine is a
into intergalactic space commander named
OSA Peck and she says she justifies an
intergalactic monkey generational
mission by saying no place on this
planet is safe forever
the universe is telling us spread
or wait around and die yeah and that's
the point spread out that's that's right
I mean if you're on the moon a giant
volcano on earth isn't going to get you
it might get the people you work with
and it might leave you in a bad
situation but hopefully you've figured
out how to get along and so yes you have
a chapter on how to survive all of this
stuff and and so except for the ailing
you know there's an alien invasion they
may know about the moon but anyway I
stopped getting around well so one of
the major points of the book is that
planetary defense has got to by
definition be International and I'm
advocating that we have a planetary
defense agency or NASA has a planetary
defense department but the point is its
international and that's good if we all
work together the bottom line is on some
level we are no longer Americans and
Brits and Russians and Chinese and
Japanese we are earthlings yeah the
virus or the volcano or the asteroid
isn't going to know the difference let
me get a little bit technical about some
things here one thing I was a little bit
surprised at you know people talk about
the taurine of scale and that that's
sort of a good way to lay out the
threats and the probabilities or
something but I don't know is that like
not used so much anymore or new AI is
should we all be getting a reading on
the Torino scale of asteroid threats as
far as I know Torino is just not talked
about much anymore for reasons I don't
know but they just not the community
does not get into the Torino scale but
you know a lot of them have been
measured and that's out there yeah one
thing I was wondering reading about all
these asteroid searches you know they've
just done this wonderful job of finding
hundreds of thousands of new asteroids
and many of them are near-earth
asteroids and and one thing I was
wondering you know it's really much
easier to find them around the the plane
of the solar system where most things
orbit do people have people actually
been searching the whole sky including
above and below the earth's orbit around
the Sun as as thoroughly or we sort of
missing parts of the sky not thoroughly
you be an astronomer of course you know
about the Oort cloud
oh this cloud of rocks and things that
surrounds the entire solar system and a
lot of these things are in there and we
can pretty well monitor the main
asteroid belt which is between Mars and
Jupiter there are untold hundreds of
thousands or millions of rocks of all
sizes in the main belt and we can see
them coming because all we can see a lot
of them coming because of telescopes
because we're equipped to do that the
ones that drop out of the Oort cloud
which is above us we don't see coming
that's a whole separate category and
that is truly dangerous
there aren't many that come but again if
you can't see it you can't defend
against and that's a potential problem
okay actually what I was thinking of is
the fact that that rocks that it almost
hit us might actually be the ones that
are going to tend to you know just drop
out of above or below the plane and come
at us again you know if there's a
near-miss these things are going to tend
to get thrown
and a way of from Earth's orbital plane
but they will come back and hit Earth
orbit that's you know Newton's Newtonian
mechanics they will return to the scene
of the crime and and if we're and if
we're there then it's bad news for us
and and those are the ones that are
frequently going to be just coming out
of the north or coming out of the south
without maybe much warning I was
wondering if those have been covered by
some of these surveys not not many and
you're again you're absolutely right
they will come out of nowhere with
virtually no warning and it's a it's a
real problem
yeah yeah that's the one that worries me
because it almost seems like there's you
know well it's a lot better to say
you've discovered a hundred thousand
asteroids and to say you've discovered
ten thousand but hey I've covered the
whole sky and and and yeah so it was my
impression like things like that are not
covered yet we got a we got a you know
well first you have to look where you're
going to find things
but eventually you're you're looking
under the lamppost for the keys that you
Bluff you've lost somewhere else in the
parking lot and and so yeah that was one
thing I was worried about and it sounds
like I should be a little bit worried
about that well or maybe missing some of
the ones that are going to surprise us
someday as you know being an astronomer
everybody in the community as far as I
know believe that is absolutely true the
other thing I was going to say was in
terms of a near miss by a main-belt
asteroid it'll come around again in that
regard earth gravity is bad because a an
earth crosser will swing way out and
because of Earth gravity it will come
back and cause or path again
the deal is as you know is that every
all things mean
every time it comes by he comes by
closer earth-gravity will tend to do
that I don't understand it I mean it's
going to come back to Earth orbit but
how does it know that earth is there I
don't know okay I ain't even history but
I but the chances are it'll keep getting
closer next problem I don't understand
that one will let that one go so what
about all these mitigation techniques
what about you know you're talking about
three stages depending on how big the
thing is and and and how close it is to
hitting earth want to tell us a little
bit more about those plans at least or
those proposals well that's the standard
plan and again it depends totally on
seeing this thing at least two decades
and hopefully more before it gets here
once it has been spotted and track and
it has been determined that it is a
potential impactor then you want to try
and nudge it oh of course over very long
distance and if that doesn't work again
blow it up I should say in that regard
as you know I mean read the book that I
have coined a term called the Bruce
Willis defense and that comes from the
moon we move the arm again on in which I
think eight days out he lands on a comet
and nukes it and saves the world if you
were to nuke a comet or an asteroid a
meteor eight days out you will turn a
cannonball into grapeshot
and each one of those chunks could take
out Jersey City or Chicago or in Nairobi
the Bruce Willis defense doesn't work
again you've got to stop it
decades ahead of time okay we're going
to take a break for a minute here and
we'll come back we have some more things
to discuss about
the asteroid threat
on the go afterwards is available via
podcast through iTunes and XML visit
book TV org and click podcasts on the
upper left side of the page select which
podcast you'd like to download and
listen to afterwards while you travel
so we were talking before the break
about sort of the spacecraft does the
other the the space-based mode of
attacking the asteroid or changing the
asteroid not just looking for asteroids
so there's sort of the deflecting it
softly deflecting it with a big black or
something deflecting it kinetically and
then just nuking it and and the first
thing I think would be very intriguing
to people what what what's that all
about how are you going to deflect it
softly it's sort of like you're going to
make good use of the butterfly effect
the big story here is that yes thanks to
astronomy we can spot the danger the
other side of that coin is there is
nothing in hand that will actually stop
one of them we don't have it as a former
newsman the balloon over my head says
that's a very good story we can spot
them we can't stop them yes you're
supposed to be able to deflect it that's
the plan far out do we have a rocket
that can do that no and have we had we
had to do if we had a rocket that could
do that and it didn't work when it got
in close and it looked like it was going
to impact could we blow it away do we
have a mechanism for doing that no we
certainly have nukes but how do you get
that nuke to go out there and meet this
thing several years out and blow it up
the technology is not there so the big
deal there is that were defenseless yes
we can spot them but we cannot stop them
and if we see one headed this way
tomorrow we better get our act together
very very quickly to try and get the
technology a hand what's the proposal
for how we would deflect something just
a little bit
if we thought way ahead of time say we
had twenty years or something like that
it would send a rocket out far ahead of
time to meet it I am tan uh judo of
course and then again getting in closer
you would use nukes I should say in this
regard that as I mentioned in the book
there is the so-called Star Wars of
Technology I am very proud to say that I
was among the first people in this
country to come out against that stuff
President Reagan made his speech in
March 1983 based on what dr. teller told
him about stopping Russian missiles with
this defensive system and as they were
saying at the time that was supposed to
be stabilizing the point I made clear in
foreign affairs in 1984 within a few
months of the speech is that it was not
going to be stabilizing it was going to
be destabilizing because if you have the
only defensive system that works you're
going to try and lop off your enemy's
head
so but the point is that technology
which was very very dangerous in the
Cold War it's not going to be dangerous
in terms of planetary defense the
asteroids ie do not have ballistic
missiles they can use to destroy us they
ain't commies so what I the point is
Dustoff that technology nuclear pumped
x-ray lasers and all sorts of things to
try and stop them that technology would
be very useful so like a nuclear-powered
laser would youwould beam onto the
asteroid and that would heat up stuff
and just this material blown out by
being heated up would cause the thing to
rock it away out of in into a different
orbit right is that what you're talking
about that's right that's right
now you were talking in the book about
not even having to
touch the asteroid with the spacecraft
or with anything from the spacecraft but
just using the gravity of the spacecraft
a gravitational tractor and and and
that's something that's maybe practical
if you have a couple decades lead time
right yes they're calling it a gravity
tractor and again the b612 foundation
rusty Schweickart and ed Lou and other
people and Clark Chapman of the
Southwest Research Institute who's an
aerospace guy they have talked about
this for years and that's exactly right
you can deflect it by touching it or not
by touching it because it's so far out
again if those distances if you move it
a couple of yards where it is 20 years
in it will miss the planet by many many
many many miles so distance is on your
side yeah I mean the earth is only four
thousand miles and radius so you don't
have to move it much more than that and
you're missing the planet all together
right and you just accumulate out over
decades you don't really have to move it
too much while you're there for that to
just continue that's right there are a
lot of exotic ideas like painting the
asteroid white or black or and so that
the sunlight will push it or more or
less than the grey asteroid that that's
there any of those make sense no why why
sidle up to this thing and painted
colors when with the same amount of
effort you can nudge it oh of course
unless of course you were an art major
you might like that but seriously no
that's unnecessary
just nudge it off course and again worse
comes to worse we'll blow it away the
painting at colors is
yeah I mean those sorts of things do
affect asteroids but that's over
thousands and millions of years so and
do the math not quite quick enough sure
do we know enough about asteroids to be
blowing them you know to be exploding
things on them I mean you have a picture
in in the book of the asteroid each
Kalla
and it's what I guess Eugene shoemaker
said it looks like a rubble pile it just
looks like a bunch of rocks laying on
top of each other and you know what if
we all we managed to do is sort of like
blow a hole in it or blow in two pieces
that are still pretty much on the same
trajectory do we know enough about
asteroids to do any I mean the good
thing about the gravity tractor is that
we'll just work on anything because
gravity works the same on everything I
mean we've known that but you know when
it comes to expecting an asteroid to
react a certain way what do we know
about this object it depends on the
asteroid and as you know asteroids come
in a lot of different compositions some
of them are almost entirely iron I mean
almost pure metal others or rocks the
popular image of the rock I should say
all of them carry small craters or
scores from impacts with other objects
which gets back to jeans shoemakers hail
of bullets as he called the universe in
terms of what's going on out there but
the point is asteroids come in all
shapes and sizes and they very enormous
ly as you say rubble piles are part of
it so it varies according to which one
you're talking about and the answer is
we don't know enough
that's why arrows are that mission a few
years ago to land on one worked and
where the Japanese did the same thing
but to try and get as much information
as possible
about our neighbors so does that mean
that if we see one coming at us the
first thing we have to do is send a
mission to it just to find out what it's
like before we send the mission to
remove it that depends on how close it
is yeah if it's 11 o'clock no then you
you save earth any way you can but if
it's very far away yes that would be the
yes more thing to do
find out what it is in addition to
everything else the science builds up
you learn things about them that's
what's important
yeah but again it's a matter of how
close it is
right so how big and how close does
something have to be when the only thing
left is done Newcomb that's a good
question too and it depends not only on
its size but what on what is made out of
my suspicion is that within five or six
years that's close enough you've got to
allow for the fact that looking it the
first time may not work the safety
margin is as much time as possible so
what they're saying in the community is
five six seven years to go out there and
again blow it up earlier nudge it of
course but if you're going to blow it up
blow it up for ahead of time again don't
turn a cannonball into grapeshot
shrapnel let me ask a little bit about
the history of this idea now humans kind
of figured out that there are rocks
falling out of space what the end of the
1700s or something of that order I mean
I remember this is famous quote that
apparently Thomas Jefferson never said
about he would rather both believe that
a Yankee could professor could live and
rocks could fall out of space but
apparently he never actually said that
but
when did it when when did he wouldn't we
first encounter a the idea that a rocket
fall out of space and actually kill
somebody or kill a bunch of people or
anything like this how long how long has
this notion been around
well since aliy basically since the 18th
century and into the 19th and it's
astronomy they did it I mean the
astronomers began studying these things
and again you do a little bit of
homework and you see that the sky is
full of them and you're flying around in
all directions so it's a couple hundred
years before that it was all miraculous
things were falling out of the sky of
course when the cavemen were around but
they put it down to God and it was
nothing to do about it
I like the phases of the Moon the
astronomers were talking about dangerous
meteorites sort of from the beginning
and I guess when did the science fiction
writers get into this well that came of
course much later but what i was going
to say was look at galileo 1610 he puts
together the first telescope and he
trains it on the moon and every
telescope that's ever been trained on
the moon including his sees craters it's
rough it's jagged it's obviously been
hit by things that goes back to 1610
yeah so since then I mean we built on
that yeah I should also say I wrote a
book called exploring space which is
about the solar system exploration
program and we've had spacecraft which I
mentioned in the book called like
Voyager lying here Mariner the Voyager 2
did a sensational for planet grand tour
in the 1970s and into the 80s every and
the four planets are being Jupiter
Saturn Uranus and Neptune and every one
of the moons that it passed had craters
again it sent back this stuff nobody
talked about it at the meetings because
the science was so wonderful and I've
been I was at those meeting
at the mere encounters the science was
so wonderful that's what they wanna talk
about at JPL not about Caltech not about
the damage but the debt the pictures
were there horrendous scores and craters
on every solid object a spacecraft
passed I mean it's an amazing thing I
mean it's such a universal process I
mean there are some body obviously if
you have a very thick atmosphere that
keeps traders from being formed and
there are some places that are just you
know volcano worlds but that's that's
the minority most places are getting
pelted by these objects all the time all
these objects at all the time and in
fact it's it's an amazing tool because
things get hit at a certain rate and
once we figured out what that rate was
by measuring the ages of feature on on
the moon from the Apollo program you
could extend that to all the other
objects that were being pelted so this
is sort of like how do you look at the
surface of a planet and tell how old it
is of this kind of how I mean this is in
without going down and picking up a
sample and dating the rocks you can just
look at it and it's a wonderful tool so
yeah you've got your volcano worlds and
you got your impact worlds and you know
the moon's gone back and forth on him
they started with volcanoes for a while
and then they Baldwin started convincing
people that it was impact worlds and
then you talk about Schumaker really
convincing everybody and don't forget to
just you love crater yeah well if
Yucatan right which they also felt was a
flow camp at one point so but that that
reminds me that you know we're on more
of a volcano world well most of the
surface of our planet gets resurfaced
you know it's like the
and bottoms they get really been
resurfaced 50 times since the beginning
of the planet and that and the impacts
get eroded away on the continents and
and we've got a lot of volcanoes and
they're dangerous I mean you know that
the theory is that at least the whole
human race almost died because of the
volcanoes and and then you know we're
entering the 21st century and who knows
what we're going to cook up in the way
of dangerous things that kill us all so
I'm going to return back to this issue
that you raised the survival imperative
is that the name of your chapter or so
you know along with protecting ourselves
from the asteroid threat we've got to
protect ourselves from everything else
so one thing you're advocating is let's
spread our risk let's get some people
out of here and and so once you tell me
more about that well as I said spread
out a die there is safety in spring
again and that's why we should have a
lunar colony it's not for adventure ovo
would be a certainly a interesting thing
to do spread out or die that is why we
need to do that in terms of volcanoes
getting again getting back to gene
shoemaker the good news about asteroids
is that they can be defended against we
can't defend against volcanoes as he
pointed out or again earthquakes
typhoons hurricanes there's no defense
against that so I'm an optimist in that
regard if you have the will you can
defend the planet against asteroids you
can't defend it against exploding
volcanoes you just can't do it so in a
way we are sitting on a powder keg have
you thought about like okay we put some
people out you know we put Neil and Buzz
on the moon and if a volcano had gone
off while they were there they would
have been in real bad shape
I mean you know they may have been able
to make it back to the Pacific Ocean but
maybe there wouldn't been an aircraft
period or pick them up or something like
that so she you know talked about saving
the earth from asteroids how big oh
projects you think is keeping us enough
people alive on the moon and by the way
you know this is something that I'm
willing to entertain it because this is
what I wrote about but you know what do
you think in terms of a calm yeah it's a
no-brainer
spread out or die yeah and again I would
cost a huge amount of money yes what is
your life with yeah you're thinking you
don't have any like for the scale or
proposal in mind or something like I
just got to keep some people alive there
that can come back to earth and yeah you
know arthur c clarke of course wrote
about this in a book called the
exploration is basically I think his
third book which is a Bible in the
community and he's got he mentions a
lunar colony and a Mars colony and he's
got he's got the Mars colony under a
colossal Plexiglas dome and if you look
in it you can see automobiles and
vegetation and all sorts of things that
dome would also have to keep out
radiation which on Mars is terrible but
again what choice you have yeah uh one
really bad hit and earth is gone and we
just evaporate will the universe care no
when I care but the grinch room yeah
it's and it's not just the volcanoes in
the asteroids or you know you can think
of any number of things getting out of
hand it's lucky that we made it through
the Cold War and Terezin yeah look at
the stuff we're pouring into the oceans
oh yeah and and and air pollution and
global warming and climate change
oh yes absolutely so what what is it
online we admit the enemy and it is us
so what I think about this
is that yeah you'd have to have a lot of
people to maintain a society such that
when the threat is gone and the earth is
settled back down into something like
normal to get a a bunch back to earth so
that they could start the place going
again in terms of civilization you'd
have to have a lot of people on the moon
and you know you can talk about the
numbers but it's it's in the many
thousands maybe a hundred thousand or
something like that you think about boy
we're going to build housing for a
hundred thousand people on the moon that
sounds very expensive but the thing it's
so cool is that on the moon and on Mars
we've discovered recently that there are
actually these basic basically cavern
just underneath the surface and that's
that's where you have to go I mean you
think you know every million years or
something from horrible impact occurs on
earth well there's any number of things
on the moon that would kill you every
day and but the way to get away from
them is just to go underground a little
bit you can seal out the vacuum you
don't have to worry about the radiation
from the Sun and the galaxies you don't
have to worry about the temperature
going up and down by five stop five
hundred degrees Fahrenheit
all these all these things don't make it
below the surface and just below the
surface there are these giant spaces and
and if you do the math if you ask like
how many people could you put in those
spaces and you know keep them alive you
know vent the heat etc and all that it's
it's in a million so actually it's not
that it's so crazy an idea you don't
have to build a city of a hundred
thousand out in the vacuum there's we've
already got the superstructure sort of
sitting below the moon so so you have to
get to people there and you have to give
them
the tools to sort of make things
themselves and they'll take care of it
people pretty good at making little
livable conditions especially if they're
increasing a number and want their
children to live somewhere decent and
such like that and the fascinating
things these same kind of caverns are on
Mars so it's maybe not such a crazy idea
it would certainly be very very
expensive but it's not as expensive as
when you first think about how much it
might cost that's right there's another
element to that should be mentioned and
that is what some friends of mine and I
call an archive the plant the record of
our collective civilization also ought
to be preserved we don't want to happen
if there is a calamity on earth we don't
want to happen to the planet what
happened to the Great Library of
Alexandria when all those viruses the
record of civilization was lost in a
fire so we need an archive of our
civilization which is constantly updated
and either the poles and off planet
right again to make sure that if the
worst happens we and we're on the moon
and on Mars we have not lost the record
of our civilization I mean we already
have this seed library in the Arctic
bulb oh gee I can't pronounce it where
we're keeping you know all the important
crop grains and things like that and the
amazing thing is that say at the poles
of the Moon there are these places that
are they're almost absolute zero and
they just sit there for a billion years
it's like if you could if you wanted to
store something for somebody a billion
years from now you could actually do
that yes that's unfair enabled you can't
do that anywhere everything on earth
changes in a billion years but
so that was a little bit of a tangent
but okay let's get back to your books
I'm going to give you an opportunity to
sort of sum up what you think are the
important points that we haven't covered
here and just convince people that they
should buy your book we've covered the
important points but to reiterate again
planetary defense is what is important
here again because we've been access to
space we've got the wherewithal to
protect ourselves
one way or another either on the planet
or elsewhere but access to space has
given us that and we ought to use it or
else or else all right well thank you
Bill Burroughs it was that is like the
opportunity to read your book and like
the opportunity to talk to you and it's
been great well thank you uh you asked
wonderful questions it is appreciated
it's been really fun